- Did you like doing choir?
- Yeah, so choir, I went
to a Christian girls school
- Yeah.
- for high school--
- Oh, only girls.
- Yeah, only girls.
- Interesting.
- And we had a choir
that was called 12 voice.
It wasn't a very unique name
'cause they were just 12 people in it.
You got selected
and we'd basically, we
had gigs though, Kelly.
- I mean we did funerals.
- Okay.
Oh.
- We did weddings
and, but weirdly the
repertoire was very similar.
I don't know why, we basically just sang
like Christian hymns, old fashioned hymns
and we'd stand there like this
in these long velvet skirts
and it just, it's just so awesome
and so I just really
liked being a part of it.
- Yeah.
- And then I did
school musicals as well.
- Me too.
- Yeah, because it was like--
- We would have been friends,
I mean, we can still be friends,
but I just meant we would
have in high school.
- Yeah, I think so.
- Yes, we did all the same things.
- Who did she play?
I heard that you did Grease.
- Okay, I did,
yeah I did Grease
- Yeah.
- and Fiddler on the Roof in high school.
- I was never cast in the lead role ever.
So for kids out there watching,
don't worry if the
teachers don't choose you,
you could still
- You can still make it.
- star in the most successful
musical comedy franchise of all time,
like you still could.
- This, I am the light
at the end of the tunnel.
- So I, in Grease, I
was never cast is one,
I wanted to be like Jan,
that one that she's like
♪ Brusha, brusha, brusha ♪
- Oh I wanted to be Rizzo.
- Yeah, oh, that was a good role too.
I just didn't even set
my sights that high.
And then, and then, so I didn't get cast
'cause they said I was too young
only the girls in year 11
can, can be the lead roles,
you have to be in the chorus.
And so me and my friend
we'd sit there like this
watching all the main girls.
So in Grease, we'd sit there
and we'd watch the main girls
and we'd be like,
oh, imagine if like something
bad happened to them,
like, then maybe we could go on
'cause we know the songs,
we could just go on.
And then we're standing
backstage at rehearsals
and a big television monitor falls on us.
Like literally falls on our head.
Like it was really dangerous.
- That's karma.
- And then we never wished ill
upon another performer ever again.
- Yeah, that is karma at its finest.
- It was, yeah.
And then Fiddler on the Roof,
that was my first taste of fame actually
because I fell from the roof.
So in that photo you can see
I played the ghost character
called Fruma Sarah
there I am, and I was like this ghost
and I descended from the roof.
It was a very big entrance that I
- Yeah.
- helped devise.
- It's very Pink.
- Yeah and I came down
and there was a technical difficulty
because it was a high school
production, wasn't that safe.
So, and I fell from the roof,
went splat onto the stage.
Everyone thought I was dead,
I became a local celebrity because of it
(laughing)
and I still was back out
on stage the next night,
rocking it out.
- Show must go on.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
When I fell
- And so, yeah.
- I sprained all of my
ribs and my, my wrists,
but luckily it was fine.
- Wow, okay.
- Yeah.